en direct de reims dominique verdeilhan
elle le verdict n'est pas encore tombés
mais apparemment l'avocat général a
choisi de demander l'acquittement en se
fondant sur son intime conviction
oui béatrice et avant que le verdict
tombe on peut déjà dire qu'il s'agit
d'une journée exceptionnelle sur
réaliste même à la fois à plus d'un
titre d'abord parce qu'il est rare qu'un
avocat général requiert l'acquittement à
la sortie de l'audience ce matin
amer un avocat de la partie civile
disait patrick dils a désormais trois
avocats dont l'avocat général c'est vrai
qu'en 1989 un avocat général avait
requis la perpétuité en 2000 à un autre
avocat repères l'acquittement alors
c'est vrai aussi surréaliste parce que
l'accusation et la défense appuyé leur
démonstration sur des éléments qui
étaient déjà dans le dossier lors du
procès en 1989 vous l'expliquer entre
autres cette impossibilité horaires
l'acquittement est également demandé non
pas parce que francis heaulme est
peut-être coupable mais parce que selon
eux patrick 10 ne peut être qu'ils nos
sens alors sur le fond ce procès de
reims n'est pas simplement un procès en
révision
c'est aussi un procès en appel où vous
savez c'est désormais possible en
matière criminelle depuis le 1er janvier
l'ennui pour patrick dils et qu'il a
fallu attendre 12 ans pour avoir ce
procès de la seconde chance merci à
munich